hi i'm shaquille o'neal i'm in little
five point george's you're probably
saying to yourself what am i doing here
well i'm looking for businesses that
have been hit hard down the pandemic you
know what
we're going to help them out when i say
where me and the general
i'm daryl harris i own moods music here
in atlanta we celebrated 20 years back
in september
you know i just love what i do and uh
i don't take any of it for granted i'm
about to call the boss lady
hold on alicia
how are you hey i'm in little five
points and i just found a place called
moods
music apparently they've been around for
20 years everybody in atlanta knows who
they are
and they've been hit pretty hard i think
we should help them out can you meet me
down here
20 minutes okay 20 minutes got it this
is the one i'm telling you
we get a wide range of people that shop
here uh millennials
i mean anytime you can get millennials
in here and they're trying to shazam
what you're playing you know you're
doing something good
i mean i'm 61. so come on
you know i always kind of wanted to do a
music store it had to be more
underground independent they don't get
the voice that they so deserve
most people say the store is warm you
know they feel like they're at home
and that's the experience that i was
trying to achieve
well when the pandemic happened we
didn't know what was going to happen
we you know said well darn how are we
going to survive now
you know i generally don't like to ask
for donations or you know i'm so humble
but you know we didn't know what else to
do you know what i'm saying so a couple
of friends suggested hey do a gofundme
people didn't want to see us go anywhere
all our customers will call us up and
say hey we're going to do whatever we
can do
to keep you in business because you're
important
2020 took so much away from us as far as
revenue
but uh hopefully we'll get it back this
year i'm just glad 2020 is over though
you know i'm saying it can't get no
worse
we gotta wear this i got my first double
cassette box and i started doing pause
mixtapes
and i'm gonna sell it yeah yeah and i
would sell them yeah and i would sell
them
then my dad got a turntable at the house
i went to a public enemy concert i saw a
terminator x so i came to the house and
i started scratching and scratching one
of my dad's records
but he was snad he was fizz and for me
music was always that
in their medium to calm me down and get
me pumped up
i want to congratulate you guys for
still being around me
uh first surprise is your biggest
customer gonna get okay want some final
kicks
wonderful how much you want thousands
hey three thousand hey
you wanna make it five thousand hey
let's do it five thousand
hello hi what's happening
you like this store i love the store so
if you come in here how much did you
spend
um about 50 bucks
oh yeah have fun knock yourself out i'm
gonna be over here
i ain't gonna lie to you i've been real
lazy bro itunes click that button
right there on the phone
oh nina simone so i got a friend that's
coming over
she's a very powerful woman okay hey
shaquille how are you
i'm elisha it's amazing pleasure to meet
you pleasure to meet you just been
sharing your love of music with
shaquille this morning trying to
that's great it's a major shock
this year and last year have been hard
on everybody but you've
remained afloat you've remained
consistent for this community and they
need you
and so we want to give you a break so
we're going to put fifteen thousand
dollars to you
and this in this business so that you
can continue to do what you do because
we appreciate it yeah
uh i i'm speechless
i really appreciate it absolutely i just
love
what i do and uh i don't take any of it
for granted
you know what i'm saying because things
could be so different right now
you know we've managed to keep our doors
open and
people love what we do here and it's
important to the community
so i appreciate it i definitely
appreciate it thank you brother
your name and your brand are big outside
of these doors and we want to help make
sure it stays that way
oh i appreciate it thank you for all you
do of course thank you
delic is good yeah i don't know about my
[ __ ] collection
are you saying this i could i could put
my vinyl on this and go straight to my
laptop yeah how much is that
i think it's 139. i'll take that my main
goal is
to have customers come in appreciate
what we do
and leave with a smile